vamos a hablar un poco sobre la
distribución maxwell walkman y aquí
tenemos una foto de james clerk maxwell
y me gusta esta foto porque se encuentra
con su esposa catherine maxwell y yo me
imagino que este es su perro y james
maxwell es un titán de la física eres
famoso por las ecuaciones de maxwell y
también trabajo en el fundamento de la
fotografía a color y también estuvo
involucrado en encontrar cómo es la
distribución de velocidades de las
partículas de aire y partículas de gases
ideales y este caballero de acá que es
ludwig boltzmann se considera uno de los
padres fundadores de la mecánica
estadística y ellos dos mediante la
distribución maxwell boltzmann bueno
aunque no colaboraron juntos llegaron a
la misma distribución ellos pudieron
describir cuál es la distribución de
velocidades de las partículas del aire
regresemos un poco y hagamos un
experimento mental digamos que aquí
tengo un contenedor y está lleno de aire
y ya que el aire está compuesto en su
mayor parte de nitrógeno vamos a decir
que aquí hay solo partículas de
nitrógeno para simplificar las cosas
dibujamos unas partículas de nitrógeno
por acá y digamos que tenemos un
termómetro pongo mi termómetro aquí y el
termómetro me va a señalar una
temperatura de 300 kelvin que significa
esa temperatura de 300 kelvin en nuestra
vida cotidiana tenemos un sentido
visceral de la temperatura no voy a
tocar algo que esté caliente pues me va
a quemar o si toco algo frío va a ser
que me dé escalofríos y es así como
nuestro cerebro procesa esta cosa que
llamamos temperatura pero qué es lo que
sucede a nivel molecular pues una forma
de pensar en la temperatura y de hecho
es una forma muy acertada de pensar en
la temperatura es que la temperatura es
proporcional al promedio de energía
cinética de las moléculas en este
sistema vamos a escribirlo de esta
manera la temperatura es proporcional
la energía cinética promedio energía
cinética promedio en el sistema veamos
un ejemplo más concreto digamos que
tenemos dos contenedores aquí tengo uno
y por acá tengo el otro y digamos que
ambos tienen el mismo número de
moléculas de gas de nitrógeno y aunque
yo aquí voy a dibujar 10 moléculas que
pues no es nada realista pero es más
práctico ustedes saben que el gas va a
tener muchas más moléculas de las que yo
voy a dibujar aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
y aquí también 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
la temperatura de este sistema es 300
kelvin y la temperatura de este otro
sistema es de 200 kelvin si yo quiero
visualizar lo que hacen estas moléculas
pues van a estarse moviendo van a
moverse y a chocar entre ellas y no se
van a mover en la misma dirección todas
así que el promedio de la energía
cinética dentro de este sistema va a ser
mayor quizás esta molécula se está
moviendo en esta dirección es a su
velocidad esta otra molécula tiene esta
velocidad esta otra va para acá está lo
mejor casi no se mueve esta a lo mejor
se está moviendo muy rápido hacia acá
esta se mueve rápido hacia acá esta se
mueve para acá y esta hacia allá
y si comparamos esto con este otro
sistema en este sistema podemos tener
una molécula que se esté moviendo muy
rápido quizás esta molécula se está
moviendo más rápido que cualquiera de
las otras moléculas del otro sistema
pero en promedio las moléculas de acá
tienen una menor energía cinética está
lo mejor hace esto y vamos a ver si
puedo más o menos dibujar este promedio
menor esas moléculas van a tener una
menor energía cinética y no
necesariamente significa que todas las
moléculas de aquí sean más lentas que
las moléculas de acá pero en promedio si
van a tener una menor energía cinética y
de hecho podemos dibujar una
distribución y esa distribución es la de
maxwell box man vamos a dibujar un plano
coordenada
vamos a dibujarlo
en este eje voy a poner la velocidad
y en este eje voy a poner el número de
moléculas
y para el sistema que tiene una
temperatura de 300 grados kelvin la
distribución puede verse así vamos a
ponerla en otro color y se va a ver más
o menos así y esta es la distribución
maxwell boltzmann para el sistema que
tiene 300 kelvin de temperatura que
vamos a llamar sistema a y el sistema
que tiene una menor temperatura que
significa que también tiene una menor
energía cinética promedio y lo más
probable es que la mayor parte de sus
moléculas tengan una velocidad menor por
lo que su distribución podría verse algo
así
y les pueda sonar lógico que la
velocidad que comparten la mayor parte
de las partículas de ese sistema va a
ser menor que la velocidad que tienen en
la mayoría de las partículas del sistema
con mayor temperatura
ya que en promedio el sistema b tiene
una menor energía cinética y pues
tendrán menor velocidad pero porque este
pico es más alto pues recuerden que
ambos sistemas tienen el mismo número de
moléculas y si es el mismo número de
moléculas significa que esta área de
aquí tiene que ser la misma que esta
otra área de acá y si ésta es más
angosta va a tener que ser más alta y si
de alguna manera yo aumentará la
temperatura de este sistema al mejor le
elevó la temperatura a 400 kelvin
entonces mi distribución se vería más o
menos así
esto sería si yo calentará más el
sistema
y esto es de lo que se trata la
distribución maxwell botsman aquí no
vamos a ver todas aquellas ecuaciones
más complejas sino solamente vamos a ver
la idea de lo que se trata esto y es una
idea bastante interesante
y de hecho si ustedes piensan en las
velocidades reales de estas partículas
incluso el aire que nos rodea quizás
pudiéramos decir que se ve bastante
tranquilo pero resulta que el aire que
nos rodea es en su mayor parte nitrógeno
la velocidad que es más probable
encontrar si eligiéramos alguna
partícula de manera aleatoria que esté
alrededor de ustedes en este momento
vamos a escribirlo porque esto está
bastante interesante la velocidad más
probable la velocidad más probable
del nitrógeno a temperatura ambiente
la velocidad más probable del nitrógeno
a temperatura ambiente
digamos que esta es la distribución
maxwell boltzmann de nitrógeno a
temperatura ambiente y podemos decir que
la temperatura ambiente es 300 kelvin la
velocidad más probable o la velocidad
que tendrían la mayor parte de las
partículas en este sistema y me gustaría
que trataran de adivinar la antes de que
yo les diga el valor porque realmente es
sorprendente esta velocidad es de 422
metros por segundo
422 metros por segundo
imagínense algo que esté viajando a esta
velocidad y para aquellos de ustedes que
están más familiarizados con los
kilómetros por hora estos son mil 519
kilómetros por hora
así que en este momento alrededor de
ustedes lo más probable es que la mayor
parte de las partículas de nitrógeno que
los rodean tengan una velocidad cercana
a los 422 metros por segundo y no sólo
eso es muy probable que estén golpeando
contra ustedes y ustedes lo perciban
como la presión del aire y no todas
viajan a esta velocidad hay algunas
aunque sean pocas pero hay algunas que
viajan a velocidades todavía mayores hay
partículas alrededor de ustedes que
están viajando a una velocidad mayor que
1500 kilómetros por hora y están
golpeando los mientras están viendo este
vídeo y se pueden preguntar bueno porque
no están sintiendo dolor de esos golpes
pues eso les dará una idea de que tan
pequeñitas son esas moléculas qué tan
poca masa tienen es tan pequeña que
aunque los golpe a mil millas por hora
ustedes no sienten nada
solamente sienten la presión ambiental y
ustedes pueden ver estos números y
decirme a ver espérame estos 400 22
metros por segundo es más rápido que la
velocidad del sonido la velocidad del
sonido está alrededor de los 340 metros
por segundo cómo puede darse esto bueno
piensen ustedes que el sonido se
transmite a través del aire mediante la
colisión de partículas así que las
mismas partículas o al menos algunas de
ellas tienen que estarse moviendo más
rápido que la velocidad del sonido y
bueno no todas las partículas alrededor
de ustedes se mueven a esta velocidad y
todas se van a estar moviendo en
diferentes direcciones algunas puede que
casi no se estén moviendo pero algunas
se van a estar moviendo bastante y la
verdad es que yo encuentro esto
sorprendente